mein heutiger gast ist peter
scholl-latour deutschlands
erfolgreichster sachbuchautor derzeit
steht sein 33 das buch in der
bestsellerliste
der spiegel nannte ihn mal deutschlands
letzten welterklärer herzlich willkommen
zum dialog immer schön
herr scholl latour 1945 sind sie das
erste mal hinaus in die weite welt mit
der französischen armee nach indochina
seitdem seit 68 jahren sind sie rastlos
unterwegs was treibt sie immer wieder
raus in ferne länder ist seine große
neugier es ist mir im grunde als kind
schon an erzogen worden
mein vater hat mir die bücher der großen
entdecker gegeben aus der konquistadoren
sollte und im grunde ist es die
kindheits vorstellung gewesen dass ich
in der ganzen welt entdecken kann man
nicht mehr viel
aber die situation sind immer neu es war
in jedem land endet es sich immer um wie
es war wenn ich wiederkomme und das hat
mich immer gereizt und für mich ist
journalismus ein mittel zum zweck
gewesen es hat mir erlaubt meine kinder
träume zu verwirklichen
inzwischen sind sie 88 jahre alt die
meisten nach sich sind sie immer noch
unterwegs
ich komme eben von indien zurück und
schaue im moment etwas wie ein kollege
auf marie denn vom alter her
leistungsfähigkeit selber für sich zu
schaffen da eine dokumentation zu machen
aber es werden keine dokumentation wer
gemacht hätte er kein angebot zu machen
ich mal sehr gründlich kenne ich für den
ganzen liga noch im schiff
heruntergefahren und im boxen sollte
sind für mich vertraut über mali wären
wir uns gleich ausführlicher unterhalten
zunächst mal zurück zu ihnen nochmal das
alter ist das nur ein nachteil weil es
einfach immer schwerer fällt die
strapazen zu bestehen oder hat das alter
abfahrt 1
manche mann für schuldig kochen ich war
auf dem rathaus steht es ganz klar aber
ich bin die fesche vergangenes jahr war
ich noch in libyen
als chinesen im irak und vor anderthalb
jahren bin ich noch mit der bundeswehr
auf verteidiger gedanken von kulisse
stimmt es dass sie sich einem täglichen
fitnessprogramm unterwerfen
wir behalten das ich glaube auch nicht
dass man durch leistungssport erhältlich
wenn die leistung getrieben haben sind
im grunde eher ein bisschen abgenutzt
seiner aber sie machen kniebeugen
liegestützen
bevor wir uns gleich weiter unterhalten
schauen uns jetzt ein paar szenen an die
mein kollege stephan martens
zusammengestellt hat ein kurzer
rückblick auf stationen ihres reporter
lebens
dies ist der verschwiegensten winkel
algeriens noch einmal belebend und
unversehrt herausgekommen
albert will ihr großer lehrmeister so
paradox das klingen mag sitzt im norden
und heißt puccini oder gar laut sie tun
es waren zwei lange tage des wartens
nach ihrer festnahme biss unsere
eigenschaft an journalisten festgestellt
wurde und ein beauftragter der
befreiungsfront mit ausreichenden
vollmacht und französischen
sprachkenntnisse uns erreicht
dann habe ich auch meine frau noch in
diese china sind ausgehen
die schüler schwierig
entscheiden
man hat diesen mai aufstand der
studenten häufig mit der revolution von
1848 verglich das unter dem fliegender
teppich hat begonnen
jetzt ist es wirklich so weit nach oben
fliegt von paris nach teheran ab
das kann ich alles gefroren werden noch
nicht
über 60 jahre reporter leben ist ihnen
da ein land eine ereignis eine zeit
besonders im gedächtnis geblieben
am herzen liebt die hand woran ich mich
auch immer am liebsten rest in china ich
sage ich mal werten haben so eine in
china kambodscha und laos mitteilen aber
das ist so ein bisschen im französischen
st
warum wir aus der premier herman ketz
steht zu seiner ersten liebe zurück
ich bin jetzt vor wenigen jahren wieder
hin
hanoi gewesen es war wunderschön der
vietnamesen haben die alte köln herrscht
aufgebaut um ein gespräch mit dem
general job gehabt den models habe der
französin schon an schließt auch die
amerikaner sich dass das schon vorhin
dann haben wir uns das ist etwas älter
noch als ich die bruderschaft der alten
männer gaben als sehr freundlich
entlassen aber jetzt mit meine frau
möchte auf jeden fall wieder nach
wir haben zurückkehren aber inzwischen
ist von touristen überschwemmt ich will
dieses touristische vietnam nicht mehr
sehen ich habe es mir so in erinnerung
behalten
fließt das letzte mal geschafft habe
ihre journalistische aufmerksamkeit hat
sich in den letzten jahren mehr dem
arabischen raum zugewandt da gibt es ja
nun auch unheimlich interessante
entwicklungen wir haben alle diesen
arabischen frühling mit sehr viel
hoffnung begleitet und jetzt hören wir
fast nur noch negative nachrichten wie
fällt ihre bilanz aus
ich habe nie daran geglaubt haben glaubt
sein also meine erfahrung in der
arabischen welt gehen doch ausschließen
die 50 jahre zurück ich bin 51 erst
einmal in ihrer kinder gibt denen zu
hause gewesen und habe danach hier auch
in bayreuth studiert und ich habe diese
tahrir bewegung niemals das eine
profunde volksbewegung anfangen doch
auch seine bewegung
der mittelklasse und intellektuellen die
sich am ende nicht wahrscheinlich leider
nicht durchsetzen konnte gibt es denn so
eine art natürliche partner mit denen
wir zusammenarbeiten könnten im
arabischen raum also zum beispiel die
gemäßigten islamisten die muslimbrüder
wie man sie ja es ist ist muss sie ein
gemäßigter muss das was nämlich die
mussten wir die muslimbrüder in ägypten
standen im ruf gemein sich gerade nichts
zu sagen
sie hatten also selbst unter mubarak die
mehrheit in den anwaltskammern in den
handelskammern ärztekammer ganz so weit
aber ergebnis anhand von heute
wahrscheinlich beinahe 100 millionen
menschen und das sind für sachen die auf
dem lande leben die beeinflusst werden
durch die predigten ihre imame hier sind
nicht zu identifizieren mit dem
bürgertum der großen städte wie kairo
oder alexandria
insofern ist muss sie nun wirklich der
mann die lage ist war es nicht im
gegenteil weil die leute gehen ja schon
gegen ihn vor wie früher gegen mubarak
es könnte sein dass am ende dann doch
die armee den ausschlag gibt
schreckliche sagen für deutsche ohren
ein gemäßigter vernünftiger ein halbwegs
menschlicher general
wenn wir schon besser aus dem weg hier
sie haben ja immer wieder geäußert dass
sie probleme haben mit etwas was sie
nennen einen deutschen demokratie und
menschenrechte missionarisch muss das
höre ich da gerade auch wieder raus was
verstehen sie darunter
wir können nicht unsere begriffe unsere
vorstellung auf andere kulturen
übertragen ein ziemlicher arroganz also
es geht natürlich zurück auf die zeit
aus der weiße mann die weltbeste nicht
lange her als kind noch die war die
ganze welt noch in den farben der
kolonialmächte gefärbtes wasser sind und
mein leben hat dem kunden die
entkolonialisierung begleitet und ich
habe festgestellt dass ich im grunde
diese völker auch in mali zum beispiel
sich mehr entfernt haben von den
westlichen idealen die briten franzosen
und manche andere ihn auch zu vermitteln
versucht die kondensation ist ja nicht
nur unterdrückung loswird ausbeutung ist
ist in die westliche demokratie nicht
ein leitbild was auf der ganzen welt
gelten könnte freiheit menschenrechte
wollen dass nicht alle menschen über all
das war die vorstellung von fukuyama
verwendet der geschichte nicht wenn alle
an die amerikanische form der demokratie
übernimmt und amerikanische form des
kapitalismus
dann gibt es keine probleme mehr und
keine geschichte inzwischen selbst davon
abgerückt und was man nicht immer wieder
vergisst
die länder die ihren wirtschaftlichen
durchbruch vollzogen hat das angefangen
mit den kleinen tiger staaten in
ostasien südkorea taiwan singapur gab es
nicht im zeichen der demokratie getan so
im zeichen einer ganz strenge
führerschaft die konnte militärisch
ausgeprägt sein oder ingenieuren wie zum
beispiel konfuzianische was über das
hamburg schweizer bewundert machen wir
es mal konkret bürgerkrieg in syrien und
es gibt ja viele stimme in westlichen
ländern die sagen wir dürfen gar nicht
weiter zuschauen
inzwischen sagt die uhren hat es 60
tausend tote gegeben wir müssen
eingreifen
wir müssen eingreifen auf seiten der
aufständischen die aufstehen gegen an
touren rest sozial 60.000 betrifft kein
sieg keine chance zu schlapp aber er in
den 90er jahren hat seinen bürgerkrieg
in agilen gegeben mit 200.000 toten
das ist keine droge aufgeregt dazu passt
die armee die oberhand bewahrt sehr
brutal seeger haft gegenüber der
islamischen bewegung die die wahlen
gewonnen hat legal gewonnen hatte und
es gibt eben auch andere fälle sich auch
wo die sogenannte demokratisierung ins
chaos in ägypten und was syrien mit also
gewiss das assad regime ist ein
polizeiliches ihm ein diktatorisches
regime ist auch eine herrschaft einer
minderheit alawiten
ich bin es erstmal einen 50 auch hin in
syrien gewesen war schon immer so
gewesen dass waren immer irgendwelche
figuren an der spitze und der jetzige
präsident baschar al assad der sohn also
dass zum schluss und des großen killers
ist nicht der schlimmste vergessen nicht
der syrien war der letzte säkularer
staat der arabischen welt dass wir das
abgeschafft und zwar nicht erwartet nun
den menschenrechten dort segelverein
wollen wir sind alles hört ihr im
furchtbar viel gelogen und geheuchelt
sondern weil man der dem iran ja
seltsamerweise mit polen aller
feindschaften ist in dem ein verbündeten
wegnehmen wollte und die verbindung
zwischen iran und israel im libanon
zerbrechen würde
sie warnt vor einem jahr in syrien und
haben auf einladung von assad assad
persönlich getroffen
wie lief das ab ich habe keine besondere
beziehung zu ihm gehabt
so kann man das nicht bezahlen hier von
der botschaft hätten visum deine
eingefahren
großer empfang und dann hab ich wusste
dass jemand von uns hat schon tradition
wir haben dass sie ganz vergessen der
präsident jetzt sie morgen 8 uhr sehen
welchen gefahren ich habe meine koffer
für einen rückfluss von im ausland
ich finde ich untersucht von micro sind
nicht untersucht worden er kam mir dann
auch so einfach auf den stufen am fuß
entgegen
ich habe keine bodyguards gericht wenn
sich als ich dann irgendwo
hintergrund aber wir haben dann eine
saison im background gespräch geführt
bin ich wieder fahren
man kann natürlich nicht nach eindruck
gehen nicht der kollege kindsein
getroffen als ich wurde ganz sympathisch
gefunden
da kann ich den persönlichen eindruck
ausgehen aber trotzdem was was ist das
segment ein team wollte ihr augenarzt
wird nicht erst im grunde in dieser
position noch reingerutscht weil sein
bruder bassem lieblings hat in
wirklichkeit kein schlechter typ er ist
im auto verrückt und dann war eben dran
und muss das machen
ich bin sicher es hat gar nicht jeden
tag wenn an anderer stelle treten
und es ist so wenn es gibt ja als eine
minderheit der bevölkerung die die macht
ausüben
aber die würden dann massiv massa
kreativen und es gibt schon den spruch
in syrien ich weiß es ist sicher nicht
die crystal soll nach baruth und die
alawiten
was ist also jetzt die alternative für
uns zuschauer land das ich eben das ab
so seine situation wir haben geglaubt
wieder einmal dass die demokraten dies
ergibt es gibt bedingungen anfang
manchmal sehr honorige konnten knapp
geworden er wirkt ein bisschen freier
sein und diese diktatur abschütteln
aber inzwischen sind es nicht die
intellektuellen und die exilanten die
seit 20 jahren nicht mehr im land
gewesen sind die den kampf führen
es sind auch nicht diese tür der
sogenannten freien syrischen hws sind
jetzt die harten kämpfer von dem was wir
die salafisten oder al qaida freuen wenn
die an die macht kommen das ist wohl
weniger in unserem sinne als eine
verlängerung des assad regimes gewesen
wäre
man hat ihnen immer wieder vorgeworfen
sie würden im prinzip diktatoren
tyrannen verteidigen wenn sie sagen
putin steht für stabilität oder wenn sie
jetzt sagen es hat der ist auch nicht
schlimmer als andere oder wenn assad
gestürzt wird dann kommt es noch
schlimmer
ich war wirklich ein ort und stelle in
moskau als die perestroika ihren
höhepunkt erreichte wand lassen und auch
der westgebiete jubelte russland hat
sich niemals in einem derartigen zustand
des elendes gefunden wie in jenen tagen
michael moskau standen wirklich cologne
vom bett aus dem mittelstand auf der
straße verkaufen ihre letzten die
einzige in das fignon florierte war die
prostitution
damals sind ja auch die großen
verschleuderung der staat später
stattgefunden
wahrscheinlich brauchen russland eine
feste hand ob unterricht ist aber
jedenfalls gorbatschow dem wir viel
verdammte deutsche wiedervereinigung
holen es kann hier keinen deutschen
wiedervereinigung geben ist für die
sowjetunion russland natürlich ein
großen gewesen
das ist nicht unser ding was da die
innenpolitische entwicklung in anderen
ländern ist wir sollen uns im prinzip
nicht einmischen ich würde jetzt gerne
mal auf ein beispiel kommen wo der
westen konkret frankreich sich
eingemischt hat in mali war das richtig
dass die französische armee angegriffen
hat und ist das erfolgversprechend es
war fannie mae brauche das nicht im
sinne auf die menschenrechte
nämlich die regierung und die in bamako
an der macht war weil es ist für einen
putsch an die macht gekommen ist ein
general der geputscht und darin meine
aussagen seiner freundschaft an die
macht gebracht also demokratisch nicht
verzogen
aber die gefahr bestand und die varial
dass diese extremistischen kräfte ich
weiß wir müssen sie davon
es muss auch von libyen rüber geschützt
waren die zum großen teil gar keine wahl
war an der wand ist im cic in pakistan
die marie armee hat sich völlig
aufgelöst dass die barcoo eingenommen
die hauptstadt bamako ist ich hab diese
strecke zurückgelegt ist man schnell in
senegal dann wenn es in ägypten wurde
zum beispiel das eine strategische
position der gleichen nacht und wenn mal
gefallen wäre wäre der stadt michelle
gefallen und es ist eine unmittelbare
verbindung ich bin das ab das alles mit
dem mit dem auto im dreck und im sand
gemacht dann ist man sehr schnell in
nigeria und dort ist er in den örtlichen
sultanat manager die hälfte dieses
riesen staates nigeria ist diese boko
haram bewegung im gange die durchaus
keine el kaida ähnliche züge hat und mit
denen auch operiert es wäre es würde zu
einem allgemeinen zusammenbekommen
ehemalige angehörige französischer haben
ja dass mich die gewissen genugtuung
erfüllt dass die franzosen seien relativ
früh an phils hoch geführt haben also
dass hier eindrucksvoll wie schnell sie
davor gerückt sind aber als die
anfangserfolge das kennt man aus vietnam
anfangserfolge kennt man aus afghanistan
wie groß ist denn die gefahr dass die
franzosen auf absehbare zeit da nie mehr
herauskommen und am ende doch verlieren
so wie die amerikaner in vietnam sowie
die westliche welt in afghanistan
es würden
sie würden sie sollten sie schnell raus
gehen wie sie wie es möglich ist
sie sollten sich auch nicht auf diese
verbündeten kräften afrikanische staaten
verlassen
es gibt ein paar staaten die
einigermaßen eric für eine große schatz
zum beispiel hat eine kampftruppe die
haben mal den gaddafi mit seiner armee
rausgeschmissen mit ein paar
französischen hilfskräften sie können
kämpfen das sind das sind wirklich sehr
sehr wilde stämme die sind auch
gegenüber den salafisten die von außen
kommen nicht besonders freundlich gesund
mit denen sollte man zusammenarbeiten
den sollte man möglichst die die
kontrolle der gebiet überlassen und dann
kommt etwas hinzu es ist weder der sache
der franzosen aus der europäer auf dauer
in mali und niger für ordnung zu sorgen
aber es gibt ein land was unmittelbar
bedrohtes des algerien
wenn die ärzte aufständischen sich
zurück gebirge das licht direkt an der
grenze von algerien gehen sollten auch
fast eine starke armee
und sie sollten eben sehen dass da die
ordnung geschaffen wird oder die
franzosen auch sollten so schnell wie
möglich damit haben wir rausgehen aber
der erfolg der erzielt worden ist doch
es war etwas gewesen was im grunde
glaube ich gewirkt platz auf amerikaner
und deutsche die die französischen
truppen sind mit jubel empfangen worden
und auf was roten fand das in einer
ehemaligen kolonie
das ist amerikaner nie passiert und im
deutschen die mit ihren t shirts tag in
die türkei gekommen sind hat man
versucht sega überzustülpen wie bedroht
sind wir denn wirklich durch den
militanten islam
wenn also algier sollte das durchaus
möglich wie vor nicht langer zeit
man kann sich aus so aus hauptstadt
heraus bewegen aber wenn man in die
hauptstadt kabul ist ins gebirge kommt
man nicht mehr
das ist ein sehr begrenzt und zwar ist
es gar nicht so sehr dass sie dann
umbringen würden die geiselnahme ist
leben
die gefahr dass wird für ihre tour ist
bin ich vielleicht bedroht in algerien
aber da muss man ja nicht unbedingt hin
reisen aber wie bedroht sind wir in
europa durch den militanten islam ja
wenn algerien kippt was ihr möglich ist
inzwischen ist eine neue generation ich
habe immer gefragt warum habt ihr keine
arabischen frühling gerne sagt wir haben
in den 90er jahren so schreckliches
erleben mich in 200.000 wurden
wir wollen jetzt dass wir ruhe haben
aber inzwischen ist ja eine völlig neue
generation die vermehren sich auch
ungeheuer herangewachsen und die brotlos
ist die arbeitslos ist und mit dem
regime unzufrieden ist es kann alles
sagen dass es gibt dann haben wir eine
sehr unruhige küste gegenüber wärme
situation die im wald zurzeit der brauch
maristen bestanden habe ich als das
mittelmeer teilweise heimgesucht vor den
ostafrikanischen komoren
das kann ich so lange her alles bis 1830
gedauert es ist der islam eine religion
die im kern aggressiver militanter ist
als andere religion bestimmt nicht mehr
als das christentum als es ebenfalls
sich berufen fühlt die ganzen welt zu
bekehren
es war eine ehrliche überzeugung und
beim islam ist auch eine ehrliche
überzeugung dass im grunde der islam die
perfekte form des menschlichen lebens
ist wieder in ihr nun interpretiert wird
auf sehr große unterschiede
ein christ der islam selbst ist warm im
moment auf ausgerechnet jene regime
auszuschalten
die sie als unislamisch betrachten und
ich muss es sagen special mit seinem
verbot dass christen oder juden dort
kunst ins happel erfahren
ihre religion besitzer ist entspricht
nicht der koranischen es gibt also der
abweichung die zurück
im übrigen ich war was in dem den
heiligen krieg betrifft das wort ist im
koran ist kaum zu finden aber das wort
quartal
das heißt der kampf catala ist für das
töten
das ist auf jeder vierten zeile zu
finden
es ist eine kämpferische region ist eben
der unterschied zwischen bett und jesus
mohammed war ja nicht mehr kunde der
offenbarung sind ein paar staatschef er
war schwarz gründer oder gw gelmer fels
jahr gewesen
und jeder soll dem beispiel des
propheten nach wie vor seit 500 jahren
zeitgleich entdeckt hat kann im prinzip
die westlichen mächte die weißen die
welt beherrscht seit 500 jahren gds
epoche jetzt zu ende ist zu ende
wir sind allerdings noch große spuren zu
lassen algerien das in ösen hass liebe
zu frankreich lebt spricht eben noch
zwischendurch für den französischen
alpen arabischen aber ich bin war das
indien ist geprägt durch das politische
ämter das tempo hat ihnen überhaupt
geschaffen
und wenn man in den oberen kasten
vornehm sein will dann gibt man sich
möglichst british das indische
wirtschaftsmann der wir sehr weit
überschätzt
es kommt noch geringen genetisch so gut
aber wovon die infrastruktur in lienz
die eisenbahn die straßen
die tristesse soll das sieht alles noch
erlegt ist von snapper da ist nicht viel
dazu bekommen und und dass diese
herrschaft des westens der weißen jetzt
zu ende geht ist das im prinzip ganz in
ordnung weil man einfach nicht eine
kleine minderheit die ganze welt
beherrschen kann
oder ist das eher ein zeichen unserer
dekadenz dass sie das die anderen
inzwischen einfach flexibler geworden
sind und wie er
bequem dann zunächst einmal haben sich
die anderen länder modernisierte japan
ist der frühe erfolg mit dem mädchen
revolution schon im ganzen jahrhundert
die chinesen haben sie lange dazu
gebracht sich april kapsel
wir haben es dann unter mao und seiner
stelle deshalb hege vollzogen aber dann
innere samen so stand es ist doch so wir
sind ja eine minderheit licher sie
dennoch gewann prozentual schaut auf die
menschheit war mal ein beachtlicher
anteil der menschheit gewesen also die
sogenannte weiße menschheit
sie wird nur noch eine minderheit wer
erst kind von nur noch von der
russischen dampfwalze zugesprochen weil
es ungeheuer bevölkerungs master slave
ja damals als die region als unser
menschen betrachten
inzwischen ist so dass russland zu wenig
bevölkerung hat und sie sich auch folge
fürchtet vor dem zugang der benachbarten
völker der muss islamischen völker und
auf lange sicht natürlich auch der
schiene sind
es ist eine frage einfach eine der der
menge und im oberkörper zettel die
chinesen werden
das haben die amerikaner es in 20 jahren
die amerikaner zumindest eingeholt haben
es ist verändert sich eben die welt so
wie wir auf einmal plötzlich im atx sind
öffneten jahrhundert an die an ihrer
spitze beraten sind mit den portugiesen
und spanier handys angefangen und die
idee taucht ist vorbei und das männchen
akzeptieren aber wir müssen uns auch
bewusst sein dass wir im raum
verteidigen wenn es zumindest wenn nötig
ist seit über 60 jahren sind sie jetzt
als reporter unterwegs in der welt ist
die welt in diesen 60 jahren eher besser
geworden oder immer schrecklicher
notwendig war das wort schrecklich
gebrochen aber
software irgendwie schöner es kommt
natürlich dazu dass die koloniale
wirkungen daran fühlte sich doch nach
europäische aufgehoben aber es gab vor
allem etwas
es gab auch bei den einfachen leuten bei
den völkern einer redlichkeit die heute
nicht mehr anders ich bin 56 für auto
stoppt den krieg hatte schon begann im
auto stoppt auf lastwagens papier keine
straßen und pisten mit algerischen und
schlossen das fahren quer durch die
sahara bis nach etwas gefahr
ich habe ein bisschen griff gegeben dass
jan hinter richtige wie auch die
befürchtung gehabt ich überfallen werden
könnte ich bin daher in lagers nachts
spazieren
heute könnte ich gerne 100 meter gehen
über nacht ohne total ausgebucht ist es
ist die events hat irgendwie etwas an
schwung verloren
in ihrem neuesten buch die welt aus den
fugen
da beschreiben sie die welt so wie sie
das jetzt schildern eine welt die
inmitten von immer mehr konflikten steht
die immer schwerer zu beherrschen sind
ist das eher eindruck die welt wird
immer schwerer ist immer schwerer zu
kontrollieren wird immer gefährlicher
sie verändert sich ja auch total würzig
auf amerika was ja noch im jahr 1991
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
schien also ca damals junger männer hat
es war wirklich so amerika war die
beherrschende weltmacht
aber wenn wir heute amerikaner ist ja
gar nicht so dass die amerikaner haben
immer noch die besten auch die besten
waffen die größe fachkraft aber die
substanz amerika hat sich verändert
ich war ist immer von handel zum clash
of civilizations dass es kulturen wie
man auf deutschland aber es gibt ein
anderes finde wer sind wir
und man sieht dass eben aufgrund jetzt
die jüngste gesetzgebung die elf
millionen eingewanderten der mexikaner
und jammern staatsangehörigkeit gewährt
darauf windows 25 30 jahren einen
mehrheit der amerikaner nicht mehr
europäischen ursprungs sind
und natürlich auch eine andere
mentalität haben werden manche sagen er
sei ja tour der ist im grunde seines
herzens ein fatal ist die welt steuert
auf ein chaos zu und man kann eh nichts
machen
nein ich bin realist ich glaube dass die
welt immer ziemlich chaotisch gewesen
ist
die größten verwüstungen im orient sind
sie nicht wirklich kreuztal angerichtet
frankfurter platz in die vom kreuz
mutter an eine episode an das von ihm
wollen stürmer und da wurde zum beispiel
ganz bagdad und die haben dann schädel
pyramiden einer moschee aus schädeln
gebracht es gab viel schrecklichere zeit
als ort und so ein ein wo eine
wunschvorstellung von einer gerechten
welt in freiheit und frieden junge
mutter würde kann man zu gott beten für
darauf zu bauen ist wäre töricht
sie haben gerade dieses stichwort
genannt gott ist dass das was ihnen
hoffnung verleiht in all dem chaos der
glaube an die religion ich bin zwar
chris kühn was wichtig ist im kontakt
mit den muslimen
man darf um gottes willen nichts sagen
ich bin gott los wenn sie und meinen sie
würden sich damit beliebt machen im
gegenteil aus betont christel manchen
auch jurist aber man muss eine religion
haben sie das ist man ein tier
ich sehe nichts ohne eine gütliche
lösung die nun jetzt die welt wieder ein
wenig in im grunde ist die katholische
rechnung vom tal der tränen es
vielleicht realistischer als die
amerikanische vorstellung von der six of
happiness an der suche nach glück sie
haben mache ich das zitat zitieren die
legende von der erbsünde enthält
vielleicht mehr wahrheit als manche
agnostiker eingestehen wollen ja auch so
diese vorstellung die gibt der die welt
die getrieben ist von von sünde und
verbrechen über die menschen ist apriori
nicht gut ich war er kann erzogen werden
pech hatte sollte zogen so was auch
immer gewesen erst neuerdings man dass
jede als junge flüsse sind aber ich mich
dann in solchen debatten einmischen
die regionen gelegentlich den krater
lächerlichkeit überschreiben haben sie
denn in all ihrem vater leben auch etwas
erlebt was hoffnung verleiht weil ich
habe großartige budget gehabt nicht wahr
ich bin mit den aufständischen in
afghanistan gezogen und habe mich
absolut geschützt gefühlt sind nicht
einer der jäger auch heute meinen
kontakten mit
mit rumänisch aber gespräche geführt das
kann ganz anders als das was heute
verbreitet shirts ich bin über das ist
wohl eher im südlibanon gewesen ich war
dass der sand am anfang sehr
furchterregende leute die geiselnehmer
im büro krieg inzwischen ist das eine
sehr große organisation geworden die
auch die christlichen kirchen ihrem
bereich wieder aufgebaut hat regional
gab zum beispiel ja ursprünglich mein
gegner war der wusste es ja auch aber
wir haben es verstanden
es gibt viele erfreuliche ergebnisse sie
sind katholisch erzogen worden waren in
einem jesuiten internat in der schule im
gymnasium macht ihnen das problem dass
wir in einer westlichen welt leben wo
die religion eine immer geringere rolle
spielt das ist nun mal leider so und die
katholische kirche so ein bisschen
schuld reiniger was ich ganz spontan
etwas braucht aber aber gewisse dinge
die auf dem der glaube ruht nicht auch
für die einfachen leute einfach ein
völker die ein fach religion mit einem
gewissen sagt hahn
sakrale musik verbinden auch mit einer
us bank of the dog kirche lebt ja wieder
davon ist er wieder groß geworden daran
dass das ist abgebaut worden sei ein
fehler gewesen sein amt zu behalten
ich habe gelesen dass sie sagen dass die
messe auf deutsch stattfindet und nicht
mehr auf latein persönliches sollten
würden nicht mehr zumuten auf der st ich
bin so aufgewachsen ist dass sie auf
latein beten für viele ein griffiger
schauen
eine ganze generation war es lena aber
wir haben natürlich auf platt eine
chance als müsste er gebetet beten ist
ja im prinzip eine zwiesprache mit gott
kann man auf latein mit mit gott ins
gespräch kommen
die muslime können überhaupt nur auf
auch wenn sich arabisch können auf
arabisch mit gott kommunizieren
der koran darauf im grunde nicht in
einer kann übersetzt werden
aber als gebet keine nur auf arabisch
haben ende
beschäftigen sie sich mit dem tod
glauben sie an ein weiterleben nach dem
tod
irgendwie für euch nicht vorstellen ich
habe keine vorstellung vom paradies eine
von der lage machen beschäftigt mich
auch nicht besonders
es ist schon erstaunlich genug dass ich
jetzt eine 90 jahre alt geworden hätte
ich nie gedacht
normalerweise starten spätestens 80
jahren als ich jünger war und jetzt bin
ich immerhin wurde schon das war der
dialog heute mit rhetorischer natur
herzlich dann kann sie herzlichen dank
an sie liebe zu schauen liebe zuschauer
für ihr interesse und weiter geht's mit
unserer dokumentation